The conversation was buzzing
Looks like it wants to arrange the
Constitution
And their system to create
Is people's
Initiative
What exactly are people's
And is it right to change that
The nineteen eighty seven
Constitution
The people's
It is one of the legal means
To change
The constitution
This means that the people themselves will sign
To have a change in
Constitution
The problem here is that
There are
Reports
That seems forced and compensatory
Upon signing
of people
According to some
Congressman
It's getting paid
As low as one hundred pesos
To some reports
It looks like the sign is being forced
And not inexplained
The implication of signing
One of the proponents of
Charger change now
Senator Robin Padilla is
Our problem is
Does he understand the
Implications
of changing the constitution
Or it will be used again
To expand their power
There is nothing wrong with
We will look at our constitution
It's hard if you have one
Own
Intention